and the first speaker is a Neil Young
who is going to talk about complementary
information and learning paths great so
thank you so much for to the organizers
for organizing this and also for
inviting me so this is joint work with
xiaochun mu at Columbia
I apologize by the way I'm a little bit
under the weather so I'm anticipating a
couple of sporadic coughing fits don't
be too alarmed so this project is about
the dynamic production of information
within a society and what causes a
society to potentially get trapped and
slower less productive paths of learning
as opposed to efficiently using its
resources in particular we're going to
be interested in the role of
informational complementarities in
shaping these long-run outcomes so what
we do is we build a model in which
agents are going to have access to
multiple different kinds of information
and they're going to sequentially choose
between them in order to learn an
unknown parameter so our main
interpretation of the model is going to
be research actually okay so we have a
sequence of researchers and there's some
scientific parameter that the
researchers would like to learn because
of informational complementarities there
are going to be path dependencies
meaning that past research effects what
is considered to be most valuable to
learn today we had a central planner who
is deciding what research everybody was
going to be conducting that central
planner could then take into account
these informational complementarities
we're going to be interested in
contrasting the the choices of a social
planner with those that are made in a
more decentralized information
acquisition process when the researchers
themselves are actually working towards
a more immediate goal like maximizing
your immediate contribution to knowledge
as opposed to taking into account the
effect of their own research
acquisitions on the choices of future
researchers the short talk so let me
just jump straight into the model we're
going to have K different unknown States
one of these states is special in the
sense that it's going to be payoffs
relat
that's this red Omega in addition there
are K minus one payoff irrelevant
unknowns which are still going to be
important because they're going to help
correlate to the different informational
sources we're going to assume that these
unknowns are jointly normal agents are
going to have access to n different
sources or kinds of information each
identified with a coefficient vector
okay so the different signals are all
going to be linear combinations of the
unknown states plus a Gaussian noise
term okay where the states are again
persistent over time and the same across
the different sources but the
coefficients are different across the
different sources and also known to the
agents the gaussian term itself we've
assumed to be standard normal that's
without loss of generality because we
haven't restricted the sizes of the
coefficients so in particular say if you
were to scale up the coefficient on
Omega holding almost constant that's
actually increasing the signal-to-noise
ratio and we're going to assume that the
noise term is iid both across time and
also across the different sources
just to give you a couple of different
interpretations for what these
confounding variables or payoff
irrelevant variables might model so we
know one instance is potentially we care
about learning the level of dopamine in
patients with a particular disorder
would you really like to know is that
level how you might actually learn about
that level is taking some sort of
measurement of dopamine using
potentially some sort of elector EDA
sensor that sensor however may be
sensitive not just to the presence of
dopamine but also to the presence of
various confounding chemicals so if you
don't know the levels of those
confounding chemicals that's going to
affect the informativeness of the
reading ability here's another
interpretation closer to a regression
framework so maybe well we care about
learning as something like the effect of
microlending on poverty that's this
Omega and what you can observe is
different cases of loan amounts as well
as the corresponding reduction in
poverty again this reduction in poverty
is going to depend not just however on
the loan and its impact but also on
potentially many other covariates
the impact of these different
co-variants or controls that you might
not know ex ante as a researcher and
those are also going to affect again the
informativeness of the actual signal
that you observe right so in each of
these cases you know the covariance you
just don't know potentially their impact
and the confounding variables in these
cases would be the effects of the sort
of less interesting code area so that's
the informational environment so let me
tell you about the decision environment
now we have agents who are indexed by
discrete-time they're going to move
sequentially each agent does two things
so first the agent is going to choose
one of the different and the end
different sources of information and
he's going to observe an independent
realization of the corresponding signal
so again let me just stress that
all of this is fixed right it's just
every time you reabsorb the signal you
get a new noise term so first of all it
actually does make sense to repeatedly
observe the same source and what you
just get is a more precise estimate of
the error
so you're gonna choose one of the
sources observe an independent
realization of that signal and then
after that you're going to choose a
prediction for Omega and this is going
to be the age what this means is that
the agent is going to choose the source
that minimizes his posterior variance
about Omega and in fact it's actually
not so crucial that you know we even
modeled the agent as making an action so
I think there are some cases in which
having an action kind of makes sense so
maybe you make a recommendation or
inaction that depends on your evaluation
of what Omega is but in some other
contexts we might think about the agents
as directly just trying to improve
knowledge or reduce uncertainty about
Omega within society so it would be the
route we're going to assume that all
signal realizations are public so what
that means is that agents are going to
choose which source to observe and
they're also going to choose what
prediction to make based on the whole
history of signal acquisitions thus far
and the research setting we would think
about that as meeting you get to observe
all of the research studies that have
been conducted and also their outcomes
this is going to be an important
departure from the social learning
literature which were otherwise building
upon so not literature the standard
model has agents observing actions that
their predecessors take but not
observing the predecessors private
information and the key warning friction
is this sort of inference friction we
are trying to back out information from
the actions if you actually just
directly assume that people observe
private information then you actually
shut down the interesting learning
tracks in that model so what we're going
to get the learning frictions that we're
going to produce are really going to
come from this new channel of choosing
between different kinds of complementary
information
and then the main questions we're going
to ask are you know which information
sources are going to be attended to by
BC agents in the long run and also how
does the speed at which the society
ultimately ends up learning Omega
compared to what is feasible
so just to give you a quick preview of
the main results and what I'm going to
show you is that informational
environments fall into two different
categories so there's one category of
informational environments where agents
are actually guaranteed to achieve the
efficient long run speed of learning
this is despite the fact that they're
acquiring information in this sort of
decentralized or potentially myopic way
in another category of informational
environments they're going to exist
potential learning traps in which agents
get stock acquiring information from
these actually suboptimal sources that
lead to inefficiently slow boring
vacation estimating the distribution
from which we go okay good so we should
think about it as that there's some true
Omega and true values of B 1 through B K
minus 1 they're just drawn at the start
of time from this normal distribution
but also you can think about the normal
distribution as a prior the common prior
that all agents share about but there
are some truth so these are the you know
known some ones in color and these are
so right so in this other category
depending on what the prior belief is
agents may in fact get stuck in the
youth warning drops and these
environments are going to be
differentiated by the structure of
complementarities across the different
informational sources and I'll be much
more explicit about exactly how but
before I do that let me actually just
give you an example of either case first
alright so here's the simple environment
three different signals the first signal
is five times the state that you want to
learn Omega plus a confounding variable
B 1 plus induce erratic noise the second
signal is a signal about the first
confounding term and the third signal is
an unbiased signal about to the payoff
relevant state so I'll show you a result
that will imply this but for now let me
just tell you that efficiently what
should happen is information acquisition
should concentrate on this set x1 x2 and
you can actually see that already really
from the signal structure because x1
minus x2 is itself an unbiased signal
about Omega and that unbiased signal is
more informative about Omega than two
realizations of x3 remember all the
noise terms are
now suppose however that agents have a
prior belief where Omega and b1 are
independent and moreover agents have a
lot of initial uncertainty about what b1
is so now the first agent is looking at
these three different possible signals
x1 is actually a really bad signal about
Omega because you have so much
uncertainty about b1 this is voicing off
the realization x2 is not relevant right
it's a signal about B 1 and B 1 is
actually uncorrelated with Omega so you
certainly wouldn't acquire x2 so the
first agent is going to choose to
acquire x3 the second agent gets to
observe the first agents choice and also
the realization but that's not going to
teach him anything about the wine so the
second agents thought process is
actually identical to the first agent
and he too is going to acquire x3
iterating forward we actually have that
every single agent in this environment
is going to choose to acquire the signal
next to ative Lee what's going on is
that it's actually socially beneficial
for some agents to learn about this
confounding variable b1 but no agent
really wants to be the one who's
actually going to go ahead and do that
but if I was looking forward than if I
think if I if I do X 1 now then maybe
you'll do that - next right yeah so it's
important here that agents payoffs are
really yeah yes so it's it's how much is
my research studying improving that's
right that's right yeah
so in some sense right you can think
about things like citation counts or
well just talk about some other
interventions actually near the end of
the talk as being ways to potentially
prevent agents from getting into
that's right it's good so one of the
intermissions we'll look at actually
it's allowing agents to uh well so the
important thing is not whether you're
allowed one or more right it's how your
payoffs are evaluated so are you getting
paid for each paper one after one or are
you going to gets rewarded on the basis
of a body of work and that's actually
one of the interventions but even
without going into interventions it's
going to turn out that in some
environments we actually don't need them
right so in this one we would we
consider this environment
okay so again pretty simple we have four
different sources now x1 is a biased
signal about Omega x2 is a buy signal
about the first bias term X 3 is a
unbiased signal about the second bias
term B 2 and then X 4 finally is a
signal that would be pretty informative
about Omega remember sure that large
coefficients are better right it would
be pretty informative but unfortunately
it's hit by both of these bias terms B 1
and B 2 in this setting efficient
learning should eventually concentrate
on the set X 2 X 3 X 4 and in contrast
to the previous example now it's going
to be the case that starting from any
prior belief agents will actually
eventually end up acquiring information
exclusively from the set and actually in
the right frequencies so despite there
are sort of myopic considerations with
this decentralized information process
we actually have no bond run loss in
welfare so I'll say a lot more about
what differentiates these two
environments but now just kind of at a
high level the key difference between
the environments is that in this setting
in order to learn Omega agents
inevitably have to also learn about B 1
and B 2 so there's no path for recovery
if Omega that doesn't go through these
variables and what that implies is that
an inefficient set such as X 1 X 2 X 3
so you can see that that does reveal
Omega ok it does so sort of
inefficiently flowing that can't be self
reinforcing because once agents learn B
1 B 2 sufficiently well which they will
by repeatedly
hiring these signals they wouldn't
eventually then realize that x4 is
actually quite valuable and switch out
of that set so here's the plan for the
rest of the talk you know I've been
talking about efficient learning let me
tell you more formally what the optimal
sampling procedure actually looks like
and then we'll turn to our main question
which is how will agents actually
acquire information will they achieve
that and then the last thing two things
I'd like to talk about time permitting
are the extent of welfare losses under
learning traps so how bad are they
actually and then interventions so what
can a policymaker do potentially to get
agencies so let's start with efficient
learning I'm going to need a definition
before I get there so this is a key
definition in the paper actually it's
it's not the definition we use in the
paper it's an equivalent definition it's
I think it's a little bit easier to
digest so for this short talk let me
give it to you this way all right but
the notion of a complimentary set is key
in the paper here let me define a set of
signals to be complimentary if it is
possible to learn Omega from infinite
observations of the sources in that set
and moreover every source in that set is
crucial for that recovery so here's an
example of a complimentary set leave me
that if I give you infinite observations
of all of these sources you will in fact
or an Omega additionally you can note
that if you were to throw out any one of
these signals that recovery would no
longer be feasible even with infinite
observations of the remaining sources
yeah
you know the subsets that's right so
it's not possible to completely learn a
mega from any subset of the sources with
it
following this find a subset of plus
another a little bits nothing yes that's
right that that would be possible
exactly great
okay so you've anticipated this claim
all right so the characterization of
complementary sets is that there exist
unique nonzero coefficients beta I get
one for each source and the set such
that it is possible to take a linear
combination of the sources in the set so
if your CI are the different coefficient
vectors associated with the different
signals these are the weights we're
going to apply to each signal and we're
going to recover the first coordinate
vector which essentially means the
payoff relevant state Omega just because
that was listed first in these date back
and also there have to be unique
coefficients so for example if this is
our set s the coefficients are 1 1 for
the first signal 0 1 for the second
signal indeed it is possible to rewrite
to the first coordinate vector as c1
minus c2 and that that is the unique
decomposition in this way the set is
complementary in contrast if we look at
this set here these are the Associated
coefficient vectors and now there's
going to be many different ways to
reproduce the first coordinate vector as
a linear combination of these
coefficient vectors this is not a
complimentary set and
it's actually you know keep in mind
these betta eyes that's going to
continue forward in the talk so one
result is that optimal sampling from any
complementary set leads to learning
where long-run variance vanishes like
the expression there and Val s has the
following expression so we're going to
think about Val s is something like the
informational value of the set it
captures how fast it's possible to learn
given optimal sampling from that set of
sources alone higher value is means
faster learning
we make two assumptions throughout the
paper so the first assumption is that
all complementary sets have distinct
values that's going to be generically
satisfied a second assumption is that
there exists at least one complementary
set among the available signals together
these imply that there exists a unique
best complementary set so there's some
set it was called it's s star so s star
has the highest informational value and
equivalently it also leads to fastest
long run morning among all of the
complementary sets so that already
immediately tells us that if the social
planner were restricted to information
acquisitions from some complementary set
what you would want to do is acquire
information from s star okay but in
principle the social planner has more
flexibility than that you can combine
sets randomized from set and what it
turns out is that actually you can't
improve beyond that so here looks to
find lambda star to be the frequency
vector that assigns zero frequency to
all signals outside of the best
complementary set s star and then within
s star samples each force in proportion
to its beta I value okay again let me
just remind you that the beta eyes are
the weights placed in this linear
combination so basically the sources
that are more important to that linear
combination which produces an unbiased
signal those sources should receive more
weight in this frequency
so this turns out to be the optimal lawn
run frequency and it's optimal in two
different senses so in the paper we have
one justification which is purely a
speed of warning justification okay so
this is the fastest way to recover Omega
a different justification is payoff
based so we consider a social planner
that wants to maximize a discounted
average of player payoffs
okay so again remember each player is
predicting Omega
and so we're gonna fix some Delta and
look at the corresponding discounted
average and we can ask what is the path
of information acquisitions that would
maximize you Delta for each such Delta
there are there was going to be some
strategy which is the optimal strategy
for that Delta and then we can look at
every time step at the signal counts
associated with that strategy so d delta
T tells us at every time T how many
times has a social planner sampled each
of the N different sources we can
further normalize that to look at
frequencies so now lambda of T is going
to be the frequency assigned to each
source up to period t and what this
proposition says is that as long as
Delta is sufficiently large sufficiently
close to one it's going to be the case
that the social planners frequencies do
eventually converge to this optimal
frequency lambda star that I did like so
in both of these senses lambda star is
sort of what we would want the society
to do and based on these justifications
I'm from now on I'm going to be
referring to it as the optimal long-run
frequency
oh that's a good question I don't think
we actually have a direct the Delta is
lower than it would be different right
so Delta is officially close to zero
that actually it's like the so when the
discount factor is lower than definitely
this is no longer the optimal frequency
yeah I don't remember so that's
something we can talk about offline so
it's definitely knocked this and for
example you know if it's too close to
zero then you actually prefer good so
now we can ask is it the case that
society is actually going to end up
acquiring information in this way
so first result let me make a
restriction on the signal structure and
don't worry too much about this
restriction because it's only going to
appear on this slide for this one result
so the restriction is that every K by K
sub matrix of the coefficient matrix C
which has the different coefficient
vectors as its rows has to have full
rank
under this assumption it turns out that
the potential learning traps are all
complimentary sets that have fewer than
K signals where again recall that K is
the number of unknown states
formerly for every complementary set s
where the size of s is strictly smaller
than the number of unknowns States K
there's going to exist an open set of
prior beliefs from which it turns out
that s is exclusively observed
you see that in this learning traps
example that I showed you earlier
so in this environment K is equal to 2
because we have the two unknowns Omega
and B 1 X 3 is a complementary set right
it's possible to recover Omega from the
set alone
and that's the size of size one which is
strictly smaller than K so we didn't
actually need the construction that I
showed you previously we directly know
from this result that there must exist a
set of prior beliefs that lead to
exclusive acquisition of x3 in the world
here's another example we might think of
there as being different communities of
signals right so maybe these signals are
now people they're experts and the
different communities of experts are all
afflicted by a community specific bias
so here every pair of signals is itself
the complementary set k in this example
is four so we have the four unknowns
Omega b1 b2 b3 and then again applying
the results what we see where we know is
there must exist an open set of prior
beliefs that leads to exclusive
observation of any of these pairs of
signals one of these cases is actually
good so this is the efficient set and
it's good that there are prior beliefs
that lead to exclusively observing this
but these two pairs of signals who would
then both consider to be
so what happens if there aren't any
complementary sets that include fewer
than a bit question so what happens if
there aren't any complementary sets that
include fewer than K signals and in that
case it turns out that we get the
opposite result so from any prior belief
it turns out that actually envision
information aggregation is guaranteed so
there are no morning traps for any prior
belief that we want to see the community
with long run frequencies are going to
give be given by this lambda star that I
showed you previously and
correspondingly agents are going to be
exclusively sampling from this optimal
set a star
and so going back again to this example
that we looked at previously K in this
example is equal to three we have Omega
B 1 and B 2 as the unknowns and indeed
it's going to the case you can verify by
inspection that all complementary sets
in this example are of size 3 actually I
think that is this example all right so
there's multiple complementary sets and
they're all of size exactly no just just
one and the best one yeah so there is X
1 X 2 X 3 X 1 X 2 X 4 actually every
subset of size 3
so yeah this example even though it's 1
X 2 X 3 is complementary we're still
learning enough from those to know that
eventually we want to add X 4
they were also the same size it seems
like they're also the same size here yes
ok here is equal to 4 right so it's not
about comparing the sizes of the
different complementary sets it's about
comparing the sizes of the complementary
sets with with K yeah so here okay good
so thanks for these questions so so here
are K is equal to 4 right ok the number
of unknown States
so Omega B 1 B 2 B 3 for unknown States
that's K the different complementary
sets true or all of the same size what's
important here is that that size is less
than K so that means that each of these
are potential ball rent outcomes
in this case again we have multiple
complementary sets of the same size but
the difference is that now that size is
identical decay so then we get a very
different outcome where there's actually
just a single possible model an outcome
which is the efficient set so even
though they're all the same size that
doesn't mean that they're all going to
be attended to in the long run that's
right yeah so X 2 X 3 X 4 is going to
allow for the fastest speed of long road
learning and that's where eventually
agents are going to where it doesn't
matter where you start
exactly so I hasn't heard that that's
because but so what is that right but
basically what we're contrasting is so
the social planner is carries about the
long-run variance reduction rate right
but the agents are thinking about what
is the variance reduction I'm going to
achieve today
so it's various reduction in both cases
but yeah in some cases the second
concern already implies the first one in
other cases it doesn't
but just to make sure I understand
you've been that last example if you
were to add a new source yep dependent
on d3.js then for but that shouldn't
change this example being not having
learning craft right right so you want
to add x5 is equal to just to be three
right and then k is equal to four and
then but this set has the do they
understand something so this is one side
I'll give you a characterization in a
moment yeah so I mean that in that case
we should just drop p3 from the B state
factor yeah we don't need it yeah okay
we'll see the characterization the other
side
so quick intuition for this discussion
we've been having
so the key force here is a Learning
Express was so Omega plus some
confounding variable plus noise you're
going to learn both about Omega but
you're also going to learn about this
confounding variable so what that means
is that it's going to make future
observations of that source more
informative and it's also going to make
observation of any other source
confounded by that confounding variable
so now suppose that agents are
repeatedly observing some kasich NAL's
that allows them to recover all K states
in that case eventually you're going to
be evaluating all of these sources under
some sort of prior independent criterion
and this is roughly what's going to
allow agents to discover the long-run
optimal set in contrast if you're just
observing some little K sources a little
K strictly smaller than the total number
of unknown States then that's going to
allow agents to maintain persistent
uncertainty about the remaining capital
K minus little K confounding variables
and what that also means is that some
sources that are afflicted by those
confounding variables may be
persistently undervalued as well
so in this case you have to learn b1 b2
in this case you might never learn about
b1 and that's causing you to undervalue
all right so now to the fenoli of
characterization so I need another
definition we're going to say that a set
s is strongly complementary if it is
complementary and also it's
informational value exceeds that
achieved by any set which is constructed
by swapping out exactly one signal in
the set s there's one more time we start
with s we're gonna consider all possible
sets we can get to by swapping exactly
one signal and what we need to be the
case is that none of those swapped sets
do as well as the original set s in
terms of log run speed of warning
here's an example of a source that's
complimentary of a set that's called the
bed true but not strongly complimentary
so let's start with x1 x2 it's a
complementary set but now suppose we
swap out x2 with x3
so we have X 1 X 3 that's actually going
to be a better set in the sense that it
allows for faster longer and speed of
learning so we're going to say that X 1
X 2 in this case is complementary but it
fails to be strongly complementary and
now for the if it only of
characterisation then so agents are
going to exclusively end up observing a
set s from a set of prior beliefs if and
only if s is a strongly complementary
set
so a couple of notes so one note is that
the best set s star and the best
complimentary set is itself always going
to be strong a couple it's five minutes
left I see okay so I should really rush
from here okay it's always going to be
strongly complimentary another
observation is that if there is a unique
strongly complimentary set that this
implies that all priors go to the same
thing so in that case we have efficient
learning because remember s star is
itself always strongly complimentary set
so that's got to be finally if we have
multiplicity then different priors are
going to be two different and you can
basically interpret the two previous
results of giving sufficient conditions
for either of these cases alright so
with five minutes left I'm going to be
skipping a lot of this let me basically
tell you what's what's in the rest of
the paper and then if you're interested
you can take a look so we have a paper
on the size of welfare losses under
loading traps so basically we say look
so there's this learning traps we're
really how bad are they and what we do
is we consider two different criteria so
one criteria is the speed of learning
achieved by agents relative to the speed
of learning that is actually feasible
under the efficient information
acquisition and if we take that as a
criterion is actually pretty easy to see
that across different informational
environment learning traps can be
arbitrarily bad okay so we can do that
by just taking this example we've been
looking at we had a coefficient bear
just replace that with an arbitrary Zeta
increased Zeta as we increase theta
we're going to make this learning trap
x3 arbitrarily bad relative to the
efficient set x1 x2 normally this ratio
of these they're informational values is
unbounded as we
another creature we might care about is
long run discounted payoffs
and towards this what we do is we define
the payoff that would be achieved if the
social planner were the one choosing
what information agents were requiring
and we compared that with the payoff
that is in fact achieved by the
community
so by the community is the order
exceptions
everybody's identical exempted
everybody's just where you want so we
can again compare these in a couple of
different ways if we look at the payoff
ratio similar arguments shows that that
can be arbitrarily large if we look at
the payoff difference however turns out
that that's actually always exactly
equal to zero the reason being that
agents are always learning Omega even if
they're doing so slowly in a learning
trap so that's really falling from our
assumption that the states are perfectly
persistent and we do next as we would
relax that assumption we allow for
slowly changing states over time and we
showed that sort of arbitrarily close to
perfect persistence as on this is a
little bit of imperfection then these
learning traps do result in payoff
losses and potentially large payoff
losses okay so I'll skip over this but
roughly so we we presented on a
correlated model in the natural way we
just take all of the different states
and we index them to time so the states
are evolving over time but agents are
again going to be myopically acquiring
information to learn about that period
specific state and the main takeaway
here is that one thing that we like is
that the characterization of the
long-run outcomes in the perfectly
persistent state do actually hold as
well give it a little bit of a change in
the states so for example the importance
of strongly complimentary sets that
remains on the other hand payoff losses
exist as long as the persistence isn't
exactly
specifically the autocorrelation
coefficient isn't exactly
and in the last part of the paper looks
at information on interventions for
breaking learning traps so let me just
tell you about one then going back to
orys question okay so one thing we might
imagine doing is allowing agents to
allocate multiple different observations
across the different signals
specifically we might imagine giving
agents be observations and choose where
to put these big observations practice
that might look like great evaluating a
body of work for the for the researchers
or might look like more the lab
structure you have a principal
investigator and they're choosing what
everyone else studies and here we have a
positive result that says that as long
as B is sufficiently large then given
acquisition of B signals every period
again we can guarantee efficient
information aggregation one catch is
that the number of signals B that's
needed depends on the specific
environment so in particular there's
actually not a bound for B that works
across all environments with the theme
number of unknowns K and the same number
of sources and so we actually find
details of how the signals are different
matters for how many signal observations
one two minutes okay let's do two more
introductions then why not all right
in contrast suppose we actually give
agency observations but now we restrict
it to be the same signal so instead of
the previous interpretation right let's
think about this instead as you have
different people who are running lab
experiments and now we're giving them
more funding so you still run one
experiment right you're choosing one of
the signals to acquire but it's just now
that instead of having a hundred subject
to see you have a thousand subjects so
that signal is going to be more precise
in contrast here we have a negative
result so all of the learning traps that
existed for B is equal to one which is
our main model or still going to be
potential learning traps for arbitrary
choices of B so it doesn't matter how
precise you make
have you yeah exactly
yes you can exactly thinking about this
is reducing the variance on the epsilon
so a caveat here is that the sets of
priors that make those learning traps
are potentially different for the
different choices of B so you fix a
prior belief and now you would change
the so we think about it has changed the
the epsilon the variance is on the new
Eastern it could be that indeed that
intervention will break the learning
trap and in the paper we have examples
of both cases where and again that
depends on the fine details
so let me actually just conclude yeah
Ben with just a couple of more
interpretations of the model or ways we
can play with it so here I've assumed
throughout a common prior belief and we
might alternatively think about a model
in which there's actually multiple
different communities each seeded with
its own prior so for example if there
wasn't a global research community we
might think of there's been no
researchers and Israel versus the United
States and you know researchers within
their country are passing down
information over time but they're not
talking across one another from this
perspective what our main result tells
us is is it the case that differences in
priorities will wash out eventually
so that eventually agents all end up
within the different countries acquiring
the same best informational sources or
is it the case that differences in prior
beliefs actually persist over time and
the answer was you know if there's a
unique strongly complementary set then
the priors are going to wash out
everyone achieves the optimum in the end
otherwise that there's multiple
complementary set from the complementary
sets then we'll have persistent
differences across the news
again and our main model with persistent
states but doesn't imply different
beliefs about Omega in the long run but
if we sort of allow for the state vector
to be changing over time then we would
also have persistent differences in the
water
and then a final comment is that here
we've looked at choices between
different informational sources good
thing to sort of think about a more
general model that works in a similar
way where agents are sequentially
choosing between different actions and
these actions have complementarities so
for example you know manager is that a
firm might be choosing different actions
over time and you can ask similar
questions about whether the agents will
eventually achieve efficiency or not the
main issue is that you need some model
of how those actions are actually
related in the informational setting
that's a very natural way of defining
those complementarities thanks a lot any
less time for maybe one one more
question
towards various solutions that are
proposed here do try to capture sources
yeah I think that's right I don't know
if we have achieved B that's high enough
but but yes I so even that's roughly
right and one intervention that I didn't
talk about it's actually funding
knowledge exploration into learning
about the confounding variables and I
think that also matches something that
you know we actually do see which is
great agencies that support
methodological work or work that's not
really interesting in of itself but is
actually an important complement to work
right didn't you say that methodological
break is not interesting it's not a it's
not something you would tell the
newspapers on its own okay obviously
it's intellectually interesting all
right